you had mentioned back way back when you
were making the first film that kind of
your concern over the state of the world
was partially what inspired that yeah
how has that evolved how have your
thoughts and your concerns evolved to
help kind of inspire this one now 13
years look the world hasn't gotten any
better since the first avatar gotten
worse in a lot of ways I think climate
change is more front and center in the
conversation than it was back then right
uh I still have hope that we can we can
uh you know turn the wheel and steer the
ship from hitting the iceberg to use a
metaphor that I know very well right we
can do it you know we're smart we're
empathetic people if we can just get
these you know these fascist idiots out
of the way
um you know but we got a lot of work to
do especially around the oceans
and you know I'm I'm passionate about
the oceans and this movie
speaks to that it's a cry from the heart
to like pay attention to what's
happening on our oceans and so on you
know it's it's not a message movie it's
an adventure It's a drama it's a love
letter in a lot of ways love letter to
the ocean absolutely there's no question
about that and people aren't going to
protect what they don't love
right Jacques Cousteau said that you
know and the younger generation are like
Jack who you know but we I know
well you can coin it now and they'll say
James Cameron said that exactly we are
in London I wonder do you know if the
Royals are fans of the Avatar franchise
I can't imagine that that uh you know
the king wouldn't be uh we actually
invited him but but he already had
another commitment uh we were gonna do
like the Royal thing but um you know
he's he's a staunch environmentalist
himself right so I can't imagine that he
won't and a diver he's a diver a friend
of mine a Canadian oceanographer close
friend of mine actually taught him how
to dive under the ice in the Arctic yeah
wow so you know he's pretty serious
diver so I can't imagine that he won't
enjoy the film he has the same love of
the ocean so yeah we'll talk about at
some point me and you know kingy you're
in chat
you know I know you don't do it for the
accolades you don't do it for the honors
you do have three Academy Awards what
would it mean to you though tip for this
film to get something like a best
picture nomination for it to you know
the the academy or the awards circuit
just to open its arms look I mean no
disrespect to the academy and I love
their their celebration of Cinema and
what they stand for and all that but I'm
more interested in the film getting out
there to to just you know regular folks
and and uh and them taking the message
to heart and you know and being
entertained you know look our cast did
such an exceptional job such an
exceptional job that I can always keep
my fingers crossed for some kind of
recognition there which I think would be
richly deserved way of water connects
all things
before your birth
and after your death people do need to
go to the movies and see this they need
to get back to the theater so just a
message to the masses about the
importance of getting back into like if
the theater will wither away if we don't
protect it but I know we love it you
know we the theaters are full again
people are coming back right so you know
moviegoers around the world have
declared we want this we want this
experience okay we're tired of sitting
around on our butts at home you know the
quality of the work on streaming some of
the writing some of the acting is
amazing but sometimes you just gotta go
sit in that big dark room with a bunch
of other people and dream with your eyes
wide open together that's what it's all
about right
foreign